hello readers i'm going to draw you a
map right now and it's going to look
like i've drawn a mountain but it's not
a map of a mountain it's a map of a
story
what you're saying how do you map a
story what makes a story pointy
these are great questions and to answer
them i'll say this today we're going to
talk about the elements of a story or
the parts that make it up like
ingredients in a recipe
many stories follow a similar pattern
good readers know what these patterns
are and can talk about them using the
right terms and this helps everyone be
on the same page so to speak when you
discuss or write about the stories you
read
i'm about to drop a lot of vocabulary on
you so brace yourselves
the story begins with exposition
where we learn about the characters and
the setting
then we introduce a conflict or a big
problem
as the characters begin to interact with
the conflict or try to solve the problem
we enter rising action this upward slope
of the story mountain when the conflict
comes to a head we hit the most exciting
part of the story
the climax here the conflict can't go
any further we're at the top of the
mountain there's nowhere else to go
except down
after the climax after this most
exciting part of the story we enter
falling action
the climax will happen much closer to
the end of the story than to the middle
it's not a symmetrical mountain the
action slows down the problem has been
solved or maybe the problem has changed
and the characters prepare for the last
phase of story
the resolution
this is where we tie up loose ends
characters reflect on what they learned
maybe you set up a sequel now look that
was a lot of information all at once in
order to make sense of it let's apply
all of those terms to a story
now our go-to has been the three little
pigs and while that's a story everyone
knows i'm starting to think it needs to
be freshened up a little bit really
working its franchise potential you know
so let's go through the elements of
story by looking at my new project a
reboot of three little pigs that i'm
calling
tlp
starbound
see it's three little pigs but it's in
space
that's that's that's a space helmet
so i'm gonna put a little story map here
in the corner
okay so the exposition
it's the future pigs have expanded to
every corner of the galaxy three brave
little pigs decide to strike out on
their own exploring a new exciting
region of space
one builds a spaceship out of straw go
with me here
one builds a spaceship out of twigs
and one builds a spaceship out of a
flexible hyper alloy they developed in a
laboratory she's the brainy pig
so we've got the setting it's the future
they're in space we've got our
characters the pigs
now the conflict
along comes the notorious space pirate
captain wolf
he's big he's bad he wants to blow up
the spaceships and eat the pigs he
begins hunting down the pig ships one at
a time i think captain wolf has an eye
patch no he has a cyber eye
he's part robot
and now we enter our rising action phase
captain wolf engages the straw ship they
have an exciting space battle
and straw pig escapes in the little
escape pod to the twig ship but captain
wolf follows he is undaunted the tension
continues to rise
he destroys the twig ship
the two pigs escape again this time to
the brick house i mean the the hot
flexible hyper alloy spaceship piloted
by the science pig
and now we come to the climax captain
wolf comes to the advanced ship he tries
to blow it up but he can't it's too
powerful
he decides to board the ship
because that's the only way he'll get to
eat the pigs but the pigs trap him in a
space barrel while he's still in the
airlock
they did it they solved the problem
captain wolfe is trapped in a space
barrel and he can't eat them now
the climax is passed and now we enter
the falling action phase of the story
in the version of the story that i know
the three little pigs roll the barrel
into the river so i think maybe in this
version they they punt the space barrel
out the airlock into the cold void of
space or maybe they strand him on a
deserted planet but in any case they
never have to deal with the wolf again
the threat is now gone and that means
that the conflict has been resolved
we're in the resolution part of the
story now
the first two little pigs the straw ship
pig and the twig ship pig learned that
they need to put more work into their
spaceships if they want to survive in
space and they build fancy spaceships
just like the science pig
and that's an introduction to story
elements now that you're familiar with
the ideas start applying them to your
favorite stories you can do this with
any form of media books comics tv shows
movies games what's the conflict how is
it resolved once you start looking for
story structure and entertainment you
will find it everywhere
let us know what you see
you can learn anything dave it out